-Guys, it can be hard to say
goodbye.
But sometimes you have to.
And there are a few things
I would like to
say goodbye to right now.
It's time for "Go On, Git!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Go on, git ♪
♪ Go on, git ♪
♪ Go on, go on, go on, git ♪
♪♪
[ Country-western accent ]
Go on --
Go on, git, eggnog!
What are you?
And why must you be so thick?
I don't know if I should
drink you,
pour you on a griddle
and make a pancake out of you,
or use you to fix a hole
in my roof like Flex Seal.
[ Laughter ]
I know you're
a Christmas tradition,
so here's a concoction
that is sure to spice up
your next holiday party.
It's one part eggnog,
12 parts rum,
dash of nutmeg,
and a twist of "Go on, git!"
[ Applause ]
Go on, git, November.
You're cold and you start
with the word "No."
That's two strikes in my book.
If you were warm and started
with the word, "Yes,"
then heck,
I would be all about you.
But that ain't the case.
So best go on, git, November,
and don't come back until
you're "Yes-vem-warm."
[ Laughter ]
[ Scoffs ]
[ Desk thuds ]
[ Gasps ]
[ Laughter ]
Ugh, that's my leg.
Alright.
[Desk door snaps shut]
Got bit off by a horse.
-Right. [ Laughs ]
Go on, git, Bundt cake.
I said it once,
I will say it again --
bunts are for baseball,
not bakeries,
and, yeah, you I know
they're spelled different,
but I took your silent "D"
and snuck it in to another word,
"gidt" -- G-I-D-T, gidt.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Spits ]
[ Tin clangs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Spits ]
[ Tin clangs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Spits ]
[ Tin clangs ]
Go on, git! Go on, git, tinsel!
Ye-- Look, Christmas trees,
I'm a fair guy.
I will give you Christmas balls,
lights.
Hell, I'll even give you
that string of popcorn
that nobody in real life
ever uses.
But tinsel, you're just robot
spaghetti,
and you belong
in a robot restaurant
with the rest of
the robot pasta,
so do me a favor
and [Robotic voice] go on, git!
[ Laughter ]
[ Country-western accent ]
Go on, git, nonscented candles.
If you don't smell like
pine trees or candy canes
or gingerbread,
I don't need you.
This isn't the 1700s. I ain't
looking for a light source.
[ Laughter ]
What I do need you for is to
provide a sniff for me to whiff,
a little whiff sniff.
So, candles if you got no smell,
then you can go on to git.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So hard to see 'em go,
but I'm glad I got them all
out of my system.